l'inspiration de vichy elle et elle est
plurielle
il n'y a pas une seule inspiration mais
si on va du côté de l'inspiration
fasciste indéniablement c'est un régime
autoritaire qui prône le corporatisme
qui mettrait fin à la lutte des classes
c'est un régime anti républicain c'est
un régime xénophobe et raciste et mais
pourtant ils n'ont pas les moyens d'un
projet fasciste car dans la définition
du fascisme
il y a par exemple un programme
d'expansion territoriale
or vichy c'est le contraire c'est la
france du rugby c'est la france des
clochers des terroirs de la terre qui ne
ment pas et donc vous voyez bien que
c'est une france du repli qui va trouver
dans la chasse dans la traque de ses
ennemis intérieurs eu un modèle de
rénovation est ce qu'on explique c'est
moins la défaite que les errements de la
république les errements du front
populaire des congés payés d'une sorte
de fainéants teese qui a pu prendre les
français qui ont revendiqué et qui n'ont
pas voulu servir disait maréchal pétain
dont kylie a indéniablement dans
l'entreprise du régime de vichy dit
l'état français une entreprise
personnelle autour du maréchal pétain
mais il faut rappeler que le maréchal
pétain n'est pas plus fasciste qu'un
autre au contraire c'est dans les années
celui qui passe pour être le plus
républicain des grands chefs militaires
qui sont encore en vie et depuis donc la
première guerre mondiale et bruit il ne
reste guère que le maréchal pétain
mashal pétain est appréciée à droite
comme à gauche dans les années 30
et quand on fait appel à lui c'est un
recours unanime
vous voyez il y a une forme d' unanimité
autour de sa figure
alors certains vont être déçus très vite
et le projet personnel autoritaire c'est
sûr on ne peut pas l'enfermer dans les
cadres du fascisme il y à bien d'autres
renya sion
[Musique]